the Black Widow V4 75 is razer's first
hot swappable keyboard and here are
three reasons why you should hop on it
it features raises orange switches and
includes a keycap and switch puller the
revamped orange switches have an
actuation of 2.0 millimeters and here's
how they sound like
swap them out with any compatible three
or five pin switches and you're good to
go they have block style cross stamps
for even more customization options not
only does this have RGB that will cure
the colorblind but super Sleek media
buttons and a volume roller the coolest
thing they've included in this is the
gasket mounted fr4 plate which keep
enthusiasts would take the light in
you've got five on-board memory profiles
for all your gaming and productivity
needs so you can set all your hotkeys
for different games and change them on a
whim and come on the leatherette wrist
rest keyboard enthusiasts vets and noobs
alike let me know what you think about
this and if you give it a shot and for
the greeners or green horns this may be
your entry into the wonderful world of
keyboards where your end game never
really is your end game